let's see if I can figure this out just
going to see if I can optimize the uh
control tasks here a little
did he use my code for this or did he
use the original
Okay so
he kind of did a mix a mix of both
I had
this I had this set up
see but now I don't even want to mess
with it
because let me look at the observation
at
least I don't want to have a chance well
I guess we'll see if the train curves
match match the
original so we will be able to verify
between yeah so um clean puff RL is just
like that's going to have all the clean
RL style code demo is just a wrapper
around it that passes all the arguments
so that you can load in whatever EnV you
want and it lets you run sweeps and
stuff like that so yes you can use the
demo file to run all of the ocean M out
of the box and yes it supports
continuous actions as
well also since apparently Google's
linking people the wrong docks
cheers yeah no worries see now I'm
worried about this CU it this doesn't
look like it relativizes the data
here might be better to just straight up
wait for Kung and work on my other stuff
in the
meantime and just know that I'm going to
have to allocate a big block of time to
this once he's
ready I think that's what we're going to
do so I'll just spend like an hour now
on the uh the hyper tram stuff
just kind of tired
today let me see if we can still fig
make some uh figure out and make some
progress here it's just the last couple
days of work have been uh pretty
intensive it's been a pretty deep dive
into a lot of these
things let me see what what produced
this graph
right
oops okay
so this one versus this one
let me think about why this is so
unnormalized for
mean unnormalized nearest parito score
is this what we got
here and multiply the distance to the
nearest
burito I think I need to make the cost
estimate conservative I think that's the
I all these transforms is really
obnoxious
I don't know why we're working in log
space anyways here
obnoxious I see why they wanted to just
get these transforms from
distributed maybe the input variables
are but the outputs definitely are not
I know what I can do there's a
trick there is a
trick normalized log cost
mean we'll just
do watch this this is a trick
normalized
conservative plus I and I hate these
variable names I'm going to redo this at
some
and I want to also change the prints
here we can tell what's going on
so we're going to do this is going to
be predicted so this is going to be
then we'll be score will
be a normalized score
nearby then let's see this one is going
to
be unnormalized
foran this is going to
be unnormalized nearest Frito score
let's see so we have
score
nearby here's your
cost so it actually gets this pretty
much correct but it says that this is
the best you can do here
okay so it's got to be my I think it's
my math that's Frey not the algorithm
here let me think about
this we're going to do
some freaking grade
school like free high school math is
what we're going to do
me deleted
weird Okay so we're going to make a new
one of
and okay
so say you have a point
here
okay and then this Point's here and this
is 200
and
200 then this
formula it's unnormalized form this is
this
prediction nearest parito so this
is
200 -
200 divide by
200 okay so now we see the
problem these go away and you still have
so if there's no point to the
right this is going to incentivize you
to do crazy
things e
if we make everything conservative is it
going to
help it really screwed up performance in
the old model but the old model had
terrible gaan
processes let me
think well first of all how's this doing
yeah you see it started it's it got away
from it quicker actually but it started
with some very high cost
oops Conservative
[Music]
normalized then this is going to be
because you start sampling your random
samples are seated
in okay I think I know how this works
so this is what you would
want you would want both of these
quantities to be conservative
because everything else is pulling you
to high cost
exploration this is what pulls you away
from it so this is what guards you
against a bad model now the problem is
that in the old version of this
algorithm um before I messed with it
they had really bad Gan processes uh and
using a conservative estimate it depends
on gum processes actually getting
good uh because if your gsum processes
are bad and do not generalize then it'll
just prevent me from ever exploring
anything so hopefully now this is
okay so making the cost estimate
conservative it's apparently not enough
it seems like it helped
prevent now you see we still have all
these points at 200 this is what we're
trying to prevent right
now so we're going to try this next
we're not going to run the whole thing
we're just going to watch the first
few
samples 200
cost 100
cost okay it only did one bad sample oh
there's another
let me look at this
though because this says something
okay this distance is still
wrong let me see
not it's crazy that the cost estimate is
that
screwy how's this the
that looks
good that adds like a good amount of
uncertainty
I should be taking square root even
shouldn't I
variance so I'm adding I'm literally
adding this squared standard
deviation and it's still not
enough which is an insane thing to do I
just forgot to take square
kernel there's literally like one point
at
distance from the
origin
I'm trying to figure out if the problem
I'm having is an expected problem or if
this is
right
score this is a pesm ISC
score uh
calculation there's just a lot of error
even with a
and this is with a whole bunch of points
the start as well random trials which
you're not going to
this see the problem with the sample
based metrics right the problem with
this you're not necessarily rewarding
good samples you're rewarding samples
outside of the
there are two sources well let me think
are there multiple sources of err here
no the model should be just the model
should just be good within its
right
so this point of
200 got
assigned a rating of
prediction conservative cost
mean was
28 you can see I didn't get any high
points
here so you can
see it was
live
okay
holy
seven okay it predicts a cost of 31
54 the nearest Point Paro point is at
23 can that be the
31 does anything score higher
than 54 at
NOP
no
no nope okay so that is a Paro point
they say but they say the nearest Paro
point is at
23 which gets a score 23.2
n which gets a score of 23 so does
anything get a score better than
30 it's going to be cost less than
31 okay I buy
that I buy that this is a Paro point and
this is the nearest one then says the
distance to the next Paro point is
seven so that's going to be what like 61
should be like
61 I'm see a
61 wait is it
On 30
should be like 40
plus let make sure I get this
right oh wait so that's
41 hold on wait
what
cost no 30
32 what the other one3 so yeah okay so I
buy that this is these distance C are
correct
and it says it's going to get a score of
54 so I know based on this problem this
is impossible the optimal score is equal
to
cost um and this is supposed to
yeah so this is the pessimistic one as
well because you can see
here the unnormalized one says
72 but the variance is
way way too low
it has no business being this
confident this is in fact the main
reason we use these
so let me see so unnormalized
forming says
this and then the cost
mean so this is a or
better do you have any tips for starting
a new project
try just copying the template and
editing from
there gives you all the boiler plate I
mean ideally what you want is you want
to be able to be in a spot where your
projects just don't require hardly any
boiler plate and then you won't have
that annoying block um I've tried
working to get the boiler plate down but
it's kind of tough with the like the
python to see like with the scon
intermediary
like if you want to build a new M like
just go copy
squared I in this case specifically it's
probably that and other stuff like you
should kind of be excited to start a new
project because you don't have any of
your old garbage code to deal
like most of the stuff I do I look at it
I'm like I have no idea how I'm going to
do this but I'm confident I'll figure it
out it's like I have the exact set of
skills required to figure this thing out
so I am going to figure it
mean getting a rating of three because
it's underestimating the cost by a
factor of
penalize but divide by the
variance that really penalizes
but statistically that doesn't make any
bloody sense to
divide your prediction by the
variance I can see what happens for the
hell of it
it's annoying that it's all
[Music]
normed
just I'm curious just to see what this
does
still you get an immediate 200 look at
this
cuz then let me see it's going to
be score minus
35 well they say the freaking cost is 15
when it's
200 so it rates High cuz they're so
wrong it's just R the wrong the most
wrong
predictions damn it I don't know why
they have the same
variance what are these all the bad
predictions hang
let me run it a little
longer I think what's happening is we're
just selecting for the worst
learned now it is
learned and the variance is way
wonder I
wonder let me try something here
right gelian processes don't like it
when you have a lot of points do
they they really don't seem to like it
when you have a lot of
hang on that doesn't make sense I gave
it 200
points give 400 just to be sure 300 just
to be
sure there's pretty decent coverage at
least the lower end
here it's completely
okay we got to figure out why the model
is this well this far
yes this still works and it works nearly
perfectly okay
how we doing
today it's
[Music]
going it's
uh so many different sources of error on
this this thing
go for dinner in a
second but I'd like to at least have
some idea if this is decent
I think this will be a more fruitful
approach is to First assume that you
have good gaussian
processes get the algorith them to work
get it to work on the various different
synthetic problems then figure out uh
how to make sure that it doesn't do
weird like run expensive experiments too
early while it's still
fitting there's your first cost
I mean that's pretty
good it's definitely an
improvement it even goes back and runs
some lower cost
experiments they're nicely
spaced we don't like it running high
cost experiments like this and getting
them
wrong these
ones it looks like it it just Misfit
this line a little
bit hey Joseph what's good about to go
for dinner but uh I've been working on
hyper pram sweep there's so many
different versions of this thing we
managed to get a hyper parameter sweep
to do this I mean my health is what it
is it's going to take 6 months to get
back in proper shape I I ran five miles
yesterday so I'm like I can
function but uh you know like before
this it could have been 15
miles this is very funny so I had an
original formula that managed to like
pick a bunch of different pido points
and then kind of like slide down
starting from the individual points like
there there there and
there we had this this one's
Jank this is better but this is like
again there's too much over here going
on this shouldn't be here this shouldn't
be here and now this is better maybe a
standing desk now I'm going to I'm going
to be comfortable while I'm working and
do real exercise right I run and I power
lift
this yeah I've got a nice comfortable
chair here thank you very much I'd
rather just get my exercise in and I did
I Ran So like the reason I'm still here
um is because I ran 50 00 miles last
year as well as hit a th000 total so I
basically did like exercise is a
part-time job doing all that and uh I
mean that saved
me so I take it very seriously but I
also don't want to hurt myself too early
so I'm not running every day
yet
um we'll get that back soon though yeah
there you go
I have my barbells coming on um on
Wednesday the rack's going to take a
little longer but at least I can start
doing some RDL some overhead press some
bent rows stuff like
that I don't know maybe I'll rig
something so I can at least bench a
little bit we'll
see isn't that supposed to spit
out yeah it will but you don't have to
touch that
file the only thing that you have to do
in order to get this to get picked up by
just add your Robo code like right there
or somewhere right all you have to do is
add it as an extension and then it'll
spit out your Robo code
file and then you should just be able to
import it from python
you know wait I realized there's a
problem with this the way I did
this there's still a problem
dinner see if this did anything
better
2350 this is up here
here yep
okay that'll give you a better
just need to clean up syon
yep that ought to work for
you okay so
now hey how you
doing working on some hyper parameter
sweet stuff
it's tough because there's so many
different sources of error that are not
explicitly accounted for that you have
to think about
here I'm actually getting suspicious as
to
um whether the gaussian processes are
really going to be able to
do everything on their own or
not because they seem to really under
report their error
though to be fair I guess what I'll
probably do is I'll fix this then I'll
go figure out why they under report the
error I'll correct for
huh that looks like it works pretty well
if you have a perfect model
nicely I said last one but this one will
be very quick
AR's coming back at us fast what do you
say the best way to apply RL the
circuits would be how can I treat the
circuits there was a company that I was
considering uh or that was considering
hiring puffer for
this um they do
you just have to make a simulator and
make it
fast is the main thing you define your
reward you define your action space of
placing chips you have to make your Sims
very fast that's the key to
it almost should be
like no I mean it has a perfect
model in fact you know what I might do I
might literally give it a perfect model
because it should be doing binary search
like the perfect model case it should be
doing binary
elegant okay I like that
idea um I got to go get food I may or
may not stream after dinner we will see
I will definitely be back tomorrow
though working on stuff um thanks folks
for tuning in if you're interested in
following any of my stuff here this is
all free and open source if you want to
help us out for free just star the
repository really helps us out you can
join the Discord to get involved with
development or if you want some
assistance in using puffer we've got all
sorts of fun Dem deos right here on the
ocean tab everything from as simple as
breakout as complex as this MOA neural
MMO and other Sims if you're looking to
read a bit more about Cutting Edge RL or
learn RL if you're new we've got a bunch
of blog posts for both of those and if
you want even more
content there are some articles on my ex
that you cannot find anywhere else as
well as a bunch of RL related
posts me answer this question and then
sign out here board that is nice the
technical physics based stuff
applications related to for Science and
fusion Center at MIT part of a company
that I'm trying to get
going I mean if you have a serious
application then yeah like message me on
the uh on the Discord because we work
with startups as
well if uh if you're trying to do
something there
I'd have to see like what type of thing
you're trying to learn and whether it's
feasible to write a fast SIM for it
generally where RL is at the moment you
want to be in a space where whatever the
problem is you're trying to solve
ideally you can have a fast SIM for it
so I can I can look at that and see if
that is feasible with the uh the
techniques that we use yeah thank you
yeah we're pretty good with uh I mean I
really like working with startups so uh
yeah we have we have some good terms
there potentially and uh know only if it
makes sense of course for what you're
trying to do but anyways thanks for